a net Goulding three steps to your dream
IT service role do you know what your
dream IT job is in this webinar and
that's going to guide you through all
the necessary steps to land your dream
IT service role from assessing your own
capabilities to identifying
opportunities and landing the job she's
got your step-by-step guide to landing
that dream role now if you're not
familiar with the net let me take care
of that for you she's a business
transformation consultant and trainer
with over 27 years of experience she's
certified in PMP prince2 cgeit cbap and
ITIL and has worked I know some folks
like to say I till and see bap I like to
just say them all and has worked
extensively with organizations around
the world providing training solutions
that's everything you need to hear from
me so I'm going to go ahead and turn
things over to a net you all just go
ahead and grab yourselves a cup of
coffee or a cup of chai or a glass of
wine whatever is appropriate for you sit
back relax take some notes Annette thank
you so much for being here it's a
pleasure to have you and I'll turn it
over to you thank you Wow chip that's
going to be a tough act to follow this
is the first time everyone chip and I
have sort of done a webinar together
like this and I just love your energy
and enthusiasm so I'll try and keep that
same pace going so this is the steps to
your dream IT service role and in this
webinar I'm going to guide you through
some of the steps to land that job that
you've been looking for I usually would
introduce myself and give you a quick
overview but I think chips pretty much
covered everything you need to know
about me I've just got a quick flash up
there I've been around a while and have
the gray hair to prove it so I'm I am a
consultant I've been self-employed for
30 years so I do know a thing or two
about finding different jobs what we're
going to do today is I'm going to find
out if you normally know what your dream
job is and since it's finding your ideal
IT service job we'll talk just
a little bit about what IT Service
Management is what a dream job is how to
assess your capabilities identify
opportunities and then really land that
job that you really always always wanted
and then we'll open it up for questions
and answers that you might have we're
going to hold the questions and answers
to the end if you don't mind just so
that we can make sure we cover all the
material I've spent in addition to what
I already knew I spent two days combing
through different information and
researching and making sure I had the
latest and most up-to-date information
for you so do you know what your dream
job is while i'm chatting put down a few
notes as to what your dream job is and
tell me what it looks like just chat it
out i'm not going to put you on the spot
or anything but i'm just curious most of
us find it hard to translate our dream
job into a detailed description that we
can use to identify an exact job title
and I can relate to this because I have
a tough time doing that myself I can't
tell you what the title of my dream job
is but I can tell you the
characteristics of that job so one of
the things we need to be able to do is
to define that dream job because if we
can't communicate it we can't search for
it on the internet explain it to others
so that they can help us find that job
then we need to be able to zero in on
the right industry companies and bosses
to work for and as we know all of those
things are what I'm not going to make a
great job for us so the problem is that
defining your job looks like a simple
task but as I said most of us can't do
it we weren't taught how to do this in
school nobody taught us how to evaluate
our own skill set we usually just draw a
blank when we're asked that question we
don't fully understand what our gifts
and talents are and what types of
problems we like to solve or what
inspires us to really get motivated and
perform at our best we don't know what
types of people bring out the best in
this either all of these are things we
need to think about before we can get
the dream job many of us
simply go through thinking well this job
is better than what I'm currently doing
so I'll try it but the trial and error
method takes a long time so what you
need is a step-by-step approach just
like if you were managing a project or
planning to do a piece of work finding
your life's work is work so you have to
know what your dream job isn't is not so
things you don't like about some work
things that you do like about work
determine the essential ingredients or
characteristics of your dream job so for
example you may need help and can you
may want to consider getting a career
coach to help you with this personally I
did this about 10 years ago I was
enjoying my work but I just didn't feel
like it was quite touching me and when I
went to a career coach and they did some
you know skills analysis and personality
assessments and things they came up with
some things that I found very revealing
for example I like to research and I
like to learn so it's a breeze as a
result of that that I started getting
more into the training side and coaching
side of things because the training and
the coaching and the consulting all
helped me to be able to research and
find out things and really simplify
concept complex concepts so that was how
it worked for me but you may not need a
career coach you may be able to figure
this out on your own but you need to
spend the time and think about it do you
like working with people do you like
working independently do you like
problem solving on technical complex
things or do you like more routine
repetitive work these are all things
you're going to need to spend the time
and sit down and figure out and write up
that list of what you like and don't
like to do create yourself a detailed
description of your Jean dream job what
would it involve what types of people do
you think you would want to work with
where would it be located would you be
working from home would you be working
on site at a client's office or would
you be traveling a lot and working
internationally so create a detailed
description this
sounds easy but it's difficult to do
then you're going to research and find
your dream job titles so once you have a
clear vision in your mind of what that
dream job is going to look like and what
it entails now you can start searching
and finding out what the employers are
going to call that job because if you
don't know what the employer calls it
you're going to have a hard time
searching it out and finding it you want
to look for the industries companies and
bosses that are right for you so it's
not as simple as going through the job
ads and and figuring out oh here's one I
can apply for and there's one I can
apply for you've got to really do the
research on where you want to be and
target yourself to get there you have to
become a dream candidate why would your
dream employer want to hire you if
you're not the dream candidate so it
goes both ways we do need to be
realistic about what we can and we can't
do so let's take a look at this I'm
going to walk you through this in more
detail the three steps that you need to
follow our to know your capabilities
look for the opportunities and land the
job so this is about knowing your
capabilities so that you can get ready
to identify the opportunities so let's
take a look at what a Dean job is not
okay we all know when we're not in the
right role we're not happy so a dream
job is not something that's going to pay
you big bucks for doing little or no
work that's just not realistic that's
not going to happen and most of us
wouldn't feel good about that we
wouldn't feel like we've earned it it's
not a job that does not require special
skills knowledge or passion or that
takes more from us than it gives or
leaves you wondering what you're
supposed to do with your life or
depresses you or makes the community or
the world worse worse off these are all
things that make us feel bad and we've
had fired
time getting ourselves up and getting
motivated in the morning to go to that
job it doesn't it's not a job that makes
us respect yourself less so it doesn't
try to get us to settle for or work
against our principles it doesn't
undermine our values it doesn't it
doesn't a lack challenge it doesn't d
motivate us it doesn't turn us in to
someone we don't like and there are jobs
that do this I've seen them I've been in
companies where that was the case the
culture was such that to get ahead you
had to really claw and fight and
backstab each other and that just wasn't
who I wanted to be so I left these are
not things that a job of their dream job
will make you do if you want more
information there's a much more
extensive list there's a website here
that you can take down and you can go
there and they've got a really good
article there that will go into much
more detail than I'm going to be able to
do in the short time that we have so
that will be a good resource for you to
really think about a dream job and what
it is or was it isn't so that when you
start to craft your own dream job
description you can take those thoughts
into consideration so what did set dream
job a dream Drop brings you to life and
keeps you feeling that way I love what I
go to do I don't quite have my dream job
yet I have probably ninety five percent
of it and that's probably closer than
most people will get to their dream job
but I love getting up in the morning and
doing the job I love getting up and
doing research for webinars or putting a
course together that I know is going to
speed up someone else's learning process
and help them get to where they want to
be faster I like going into companies
and helping them solve problems so that
they can achieve their objectives and
their life's goals so that's what keeps
me going you'll have to figure out what
it is that keeps you going but your
dream job will bring you to life and
keep you feeling that way not to say you
won't have some bad days of course you
will but for the overall the net effect
is that you're happy doing it
it rewards you well for your special
skills knowledge passion time and energy
it doesn't expect that you're going to
get paid minimum wage when you've spent
years building skill sets and
competencies and time and energy so you
can contribute to an organization to
really help them cheat Eve their
objectives it gives it feels like and I
should have this light saying feels like
it gives more than it takes of course
the dream candidates going to give more
than it takes as well and that's when we
know we have a good fit when both
parties feel like they're getting more
out of it than they're giving it's a
very good fit it makes you excited to
start your day involves working with
people you love well maybe love is a bit
of an exception but you like working
with them and you love going into work
and being with them in that work
environment it makes your community a
better place it provides you with
benefits and perks that are meaningful
to you and this is an important one
pardonnez benefits and perks that are of
no value to you don't motivate you and
don't really a thank you and they don't
really show that the company you've
worked for has thought about what you
want and how it can benefit you so for
example my kids are grown up I live on
my own so if a company wants to give me
a family vacation as a benefit that
really doesn't mean much to me besides I
rarely take vacations but if they want
to give me some free training then
that's a perk that's meaningful to me so
you have to figure out what the
meaningful perks are to you so when you
negotiate and sign on for that dream job
you make sure that this happens because
this will be part of your dream job it
doesn't let you settle and allows you to
make the best of yourself so creates an
environment where you feel challenged
but not overwhelmed and you're motivated
to continue to evolve and grow and do
better it highlights your best qualities
and abilities none of us are perfect
none
this are good at everything I certainly
have weaknesses and many of them I also
have many strengths and the dream job
for you will be the one that takes your
best qualities and abilities and really
maximizes and focuses on those it
upholds your principles and allows you
to live with them so if you don't like
hurting people you're not going to want
a job where you have to rip off
customers for example in order for that
company to make money it challenges to
you to grow evolve and succeed and turns
you into the person that you were meant
to be again this is from the same
website you can get more information
there but just some things to think
about with your dream job certainly
things that many of us would maybe
consider unrealistic to expect from our
dream job but as my dream job really
make my community in my world better
well yes it should for example I really
like it when I work in the healthcare
field if I'm doing a consulting project
or a business transformation with a
healthcare provider because I know
there's a secondary impact to helping
people of the work I do not simply
making money although that's an
important part of our world as well so
we know what a dream job isn't isn't and
what we can expect from it one of the
things we need to look at if we're
talking about IT service rules is do you
are you more comfortable doing a
management role or in a practitioner
rule so do you like the planning the
integrating the working with people and
getting them motivated and making it
sure all things come together or would
you rather be more focused on the task
and more technical in nature you don't
have to be technical practitioner rules
can be hands are certainly more hands-on
than the management roles but they may
or may not be technical in nature and
I'm going to show you some examples of
rules that are not technical in nature
as well if your preferences are more
towards the manager
rolls then you might want to consider
looking into itsm or IT service
management and some of the
certifications and that around those and
this experience around that so once you
know if you're more suited for these
that will help that's her half the
battle my father was a mechanic at
DuPont here in Canada he was a
first-class mechanic there and he'd been
offered several promotions which he
turned down because he didn't like the
management rule that wasn't his thing he
wanted the hands-on doing the work so
again you need to know yourself well
before you can land your dream job so if
we talk about IT service management what
is it it relates to all the managerial
aspects of IT so it covers planning
support delivery security infrastructure
and any other aspects of delivering IT
services it focuses on customer
satisfaction and business goals so they
are at the core of itsm success and
you've probably heard the word itsm
bandied around quite a bit over recent
years so it's a little bit more
information about it IT service
management if you're on the management
side involves aligning enterprise IT
services with business needs to support
achieving strategic and operational
objectives its primary focus is on
customer satisfaction and business goals
and it gauges the end-to-end delivery of
IT solutions and measures things like
service level expectations at the end
users and whether those have been met
and how technical IT manages services to
deliver on those expectations so why is
this important why is it important to
understand this tool and your dream job
because you'll remember I said we have
to become a dream candidate well if
organizations are trying to accomplish
this
in IT Service Management then we're
going to have to position ourselves and
think about things in a way that shows
how we can help them contribute to
aligning our services to business needs
and that we understand what the business
needs are and we understand what
customer satisfaction what that means so
that doesn't mean I've answered the
Service Desk all within five seconds and
hung up if it took 15 for the customer
to be satisfied and this is where we
have to think about how we fit in to
that big picture so how has IT Service
Management changed well traditional IT
focus primarily on technology IT service
management focuses on process all of the
technology if you take the ITIL
foundation course they'll talk about the
4 p's partners people products and then
the fourth p is process I can have
everything else perfect but I can't
bring that process together to make it
work effectively it's not going to do
any good traditional IT was more
firefighting whereas itsm tries to be
more preventative so it's more proactive
than reactive it focuses on customers
rather than users and you might ask well
what's the difference there's a big
difference in the mindset that we use
when we talk about users versus
customers customers we think of people
who pay and have choices users we think
of as people who have to use the service
or have to use the system but really
don't have any other choice it sets a
subtle but very different mindset that
sets you apart when you think about it
this way from others who are providing
services centralized and done in-house
nowadays very little is in-house a lot
of its distributed so we're getting
different pieces and parts of the
services that we provide to our
customers from various sources so it
takes a lot more integration and it
takes a lot more knowledge and
understanding of that
traditional IT had more it was more
isolated into silos today it's more
integrated and it's enterprise-wide it's
not the one off ad-hoc here's how we're
going to do it we want a repeatable
accountable delivery of services and we
see things like agile and rapid
application development and we see
things like test-driven development so
that we can do more frequent updates and
changes that speaks to the repeatable
accountable nature of those services
that we're delivering they were informal
processes in the past now we're looking
at best practices and we see this in the
explosion of requirement from employers
requiring people to have certifications
to demonstrate they understand what
those formal best practices are they
were IT internal perspective in the past
we're now looking at it from a business
perspective we should have been doing
this all along because I t was there to
meet the needs of the business but
somehow in the silos people lost sight
of the fact that we're there to support
the business so there has to be that
business perspective you'll need to
convey you understand that when you're
trying to apply for your ideal job its
operations specific as in terms of
specific portions of the initiative so
it might be looking at maintaining the
network or maintaining the software or
maintaining the helpdesk here we're
looking at a service orientation which
can cut across those different
operations so we're trying to look at
how does it look from the business
perspective in terms of the services we
provide as IT professionals so subtle
but important differences in some areas
and fairly significant differences when
we look at the integrated rather than
siloed for example and repeatable and
accountable rather than ad hoc so what
are some
IT service rules things like a service
manager would be a management related
rule where they're looking at how to
provide a service across the different
processes within the organization so
they're responsible for making sure that
the entirety of the service meets the
customer requirements there's the
service owner who represents the company
and is responsible for making sure that
we know what the service levels are and
how they get delivered to different
types of market segments that we may be
targeting we might have someone who's in
an Operations Manager so they're not
necessarily dealing with the customers
face-to-face as much but they're making
sure that the day-to-day infrastructure
and operations are up and running and
working properly we have process
managers who will take a segment of the
process maybe in the operations and are
making sure it runs well such as the
Service Desk process or the problem
resolution process or the change
management process we have IT service
continuity managers who coordinate all I
service continuity activities within an
organization to ensure that they can
recover in this in case of a severe
catastrophe that would cause them to
have to sort of reinitiate everything
and there are many many many other rules
but these are more along the management
side you'll have to do your homework
after you've designed your own ideal or
dream job description and see which
generic roles align closest to what you
want to do and there's tons of
information out there on that ITIL is
one of the frameworks for itsm and it
has a good description of many of the
generic rules so if you're looking for a
place to go and find that that's one ask
one area that you can you can look for
it some practitioner type roles would be
things like administrative support so
you're looking at gathering service data
looking at service
boarding tools maintaining the service
catalog for example another practitioner
type role of practitioner being
something you serve works and the hands
on carrying out and actually executing
activities in the process would be
performance whoops would be performance
and capacity analyst so you're analyzing
the capacity and performance issues so
you can determine ways to improve on
both levels at acceptable costs you
might be a hardware engineer so you're
maintaining a physical hardware for
proper operation and coordination so
that you're installing you're looking at
moves repairs working with third-party
vendors to get that to happen you could
be a business liaison if you're a
practitioner so you're the single point
of contact so gay these give you an idea
of the types of things you need to
consider when you're figuring out what
your dream job is you don't want to be a
business liaison if people drive you
crazy you might want to be a hardware
engineer where you're dealing more with
solving problems on dealing with
information and the hardware yeah you
always need to deal with people but if
you know it is talking to people all day
is not your thing then this wouldn't be
a dream job for you if you like
organizing things and making sure that
they're connected and that everything is
neat and tidy and and everybody knows
and there's they can access the
information they need a configuration
librarian looking in configuration
management might be something to to
consider so again you really need to
figure out what you like and what your
strengths are and then write your own
job description your dream job
description and then compare it to some
of these generic roles and then you can
assess and start looking at this will
help give you some ideas of job titles
to search for so that when you are in
the state where you're ready to start
looking for those opportunities you know
what types of things to reach out to all
right
so we have an idea of what our dream job
is we figure that out we've done the
homework we know what we're good at we
may have asked our friends to tell us
what they think we're good at or
co-workers things like that now we have
to figure out what's my capability am I
the dream candidate or not start with
where you are today so know where you
stand in terms of your current skills
your current job experience your
industry knowledge work experience your
work ethic and your attitude these are
all things that are going to help you
target which job which industry which
company what type of corporate cultures
and what type of people you like to work
with once you figure that out then you
need to figure out how to become the
dream candidate and a dream candidate is
the perfect tire they're not only the
right person for the job they're the
only one the company wants they see you
they see your experience and they say we
have to have that person because they
will help us get to where we want to go
and they will fit in perfectly in our
environment and with the rest of our
team so assess your capabilities start
with where you are now you have a lot
more skills and experience and you
probably realize there's a few people
out there who are pretty big on
themselves and aren't really warranted
and being so but they're the minority
most people underestimate their skills
they don't know how to articulate their
skill set or present their work
experience and how to convey their work
ethics and their their attitude to
others and that's what you need to
figure out how to do start by assessing
them so that you know how to label them
and to talk about them let's take a look
at how to become a dream candidate dream
dog equals dream candidate dream
candidates don't compete for jobs
because they're seriously the only one
the hiring manager will consider for the
job and some of you will have had this
experience where somebody meets you and
or you've gone in
you've done a little bit of work and
they just keep keeping you on they keep
finding work or they create a position
for you because they know the
organization needs you and they know
that dream candidates are as few and far
between as dream jobs are so when they
find you they will find a way to get you
in I've for example worked on contracts
where I've gone in to do a 2 lutherie
week assessment for them and been there
for years they found a position because
they knew that I fit what they were
currently trying to do that's what a
dream candidate is not to say that it
was a dream candidate but I was better
than the ones that they had to date I
guess they will wait for you to become
available so if you're busy and you're
the right person and you're perfect for
their organization they'll wait for a
month or two or whatever to get you on
board they will bend over and create
jobs to bring you in as I said there
people of managers dream of finding and
hiring but never do just like most of us
never find our dream job most hiring and
companies that are hiring fail to find
their dream candidate as well so to find
your dream job become the dream
candidate for that job people think that
dream candidates are too perfect for the
job and can't be true or they won't be
interested in it or you know won't be
available when you need them but just
like you think that dream job maybe not
be out there the reverse is also true so
put the work in get ready get out there
market yourself another thing to think
about is that dream candidates don't
have to talk themselves into positions
your previous work and your work
portfolio we're going to talk about the
work portfolio in just a moment those
things already tell you you excel at the
job and that you're the right person so
all the company hiring or the
interviewer has to do is see if your
personalities match within the
organization and work out the details
remember when we talked about the
dreamed the dream job and how you
working with the people that you were
working with that was part of a dream
having a dream job well hiring HR and
hiring managers have to be very careful
who they bring into organizations to
make sure that those personalities stay
in harmony otherwise it makes a mess of
the whole thing for everybody so how do
you become a dream candidate well you
start with where you are as I've already
said you do a gap analysis on your
current capabilities certifications
experience and experience against those
required for the dream job it's okay
let's back up for just a moment we said
we have to start out by defining our
dream job and knowing what it is so
knowing ourselves really well and what
we like to do and what our strengths and
weaknesses are writing our own job
description if we could do anything we
wanted to what would it be then looking
at what that job might be called in the
marketplace so now that I know what that
job might be called in the marketplace
let's look at what people hiring for
those types of positions are looking for
so if they're looking for certain
certain certain certifications or
certain numbers of years of experience
or certain types of roles that you've
played then get that experience so do
that gap analysis to what those
positions are asking for versus what you
currently have and start filling those
gaps if your dream job requires you to
have you know a project management
certification or a a cisco networking
type certification get them 20 years ago
30 years ago when I started working you
didn't here are these certifications I
never heard of professional project
manager or needing a microsoft
certification or any of those things
there are a governance and I enterprise
IT you went to school you got your
diploma or your cert your your degree
and you got a job and it was that simple
at least it seemed that simple
nowadays that's not quite enough more
and more jobs requiring those
certifications so if you're looking for
a job and can't find it this could be
part of the reason why so do your
research figure out what it is that
you're missing once you've got the
training and the right certifications
and you've managed to acquire the right
certification actually don't wait till
then start now but continue especially
hard when you've got all the
certifications by networking with others
use social media post blog sites get
yourself known use professional
organizations so for example I belong to
the certified business analysis
professionals project management
institute so you can get out and network
with others and find out and keep
abreast of what's happening in the job
market as well so it used to be enough
to just be PMP certified i have seen
contracts now that are requiring both
PMP and prints to as well as six sigma
fortunately not very many but it shows
trends in the order in the job market
you need to be constantly watching for
those because even when you land your
dream job the ground can change under
your feet and you need to be one step
ahead of it professional organizations
can help us with this if you can't get a
job that gives you the experience you
need consider doing volunteer work there
are lots of organizations in the
community that could use professionals
to help them keep their organizations
running and do good work that helps
improve our communities and the world
over all and end and you know not to be
too idealistic but if you really need
the experience try doing some volunteer
work to get it attend conferences if
that's possible it's not feasible for
everyone sometimes the travel is too
much especially if you have small kids
at home and things like that but these
are ways to learn and to network with
other people and find out what's
happening in your specialty talk about
the job you want now that's
obvious but you know what I don't hear a
lot of people talking about the job they
want I hear them talking about the job
they don't want and what they don't like
and that comes across as very negative
and it comes across as well yours don't
like the job but what are you doing
about it talk about the job you want
make sure people around you know what
you're looking for it doesn't mean
you're constantly selling them but you
can boy I wish I had a job that did
whatever or these are aspects of a job
or if you hear someone talking about
something they're doing in their job
that sounds like it's part of your dream
job make sure people know that that's
something you enjoy because if they
don't know and they hear about something
that you might be interested in they
won't tell you because they'll think
that it's something you're just not
interested in so make sure the world
around you knows what you like what
you're interested in and the type of job
you'd like and do it in a nice
diplomatic way that they don't feel
pressured so as I've already mentioned
there are more and more organizations
requiring certifications and I'm going
to get to some stats in just a moment
for you I've thrown up just a few
obviously in an hour that we have we
won't have time to go through all of
them unfortunately but it shows you the
wide range from you know six sigma
certification for quality and continuous
improvement looking at being a citric
certified professional governance and
enterprise IT Microsoft has several it
looks like I chopped off the top of my
T's here I'm so sorry for fundamentals
of IT or solutions developer even amazon
has gotten in on the game and has a an
amazon certified developer for solutions
as well so so check out once you know
your dream job the area you want to be
in if you love security for example and
you're going to want to look at getting
the certified information security
managers one of the top certifications
so do check them out okay if you go to I
like toms IT pro he has lots of good
articles on various different things
whenever I've had to do research from
hardware to what else what when I was
researching for this to try and get you
the most current
Tom's IT pro best IT certifications for
2016 he'll give you a rundown of a
number of them more than I have on the
screen here and you can get more
information sort of what they might be
useful for and where in so I found lots
of stuff that was for you know 2010 2012
but this was the most recent and most
comprehensive list of IT certifications
that I found so check that out so I
promised you some stats so here they are
getting a certification takes a lot of
time because there's a lot of study
there's the research and figuring out
which certification you need and then
you've also got to spend all that time
to do the studying taking the course
that cost you money and really what's
the value well compte ia the IT industry
trade association satiation gave us an
insight see at a recent survey and what
they found is that sixty-five percent of
employers use IT certifications to
differentiate between equally qualified
candidates so just having the
certification won't get you the job
that's not what we're promoting here but
all other things being equal it
definitely will ah maybe I'm overstating
it definitely it generally will if you
are a really poor attitude and you go to
the interview and you've got the
certificate and you're equally qualified
but they see you're not a good fit for
their organization from a personality
perspective you could still lose out
there but all other things being equal
this is going to help you it's a very
competitive marketplace we need all the
advantages we can get seventy two
percent of employers are now using IT
certifications as a requirement okay so
not to differentiate but you must have
the certification to do certain job
roles you need to when you're doing your
research about your dream job figure out
if the role you want is one of those
jobs that most organizations want a
certification in that's high seventy-two
percent use those certifications as a
requirement for some jobs sixty percent
of organizations often use IT
certifications to confirm a candidate
subject matter knowledge or expertise so
rather than having to create long lists
of subject matter questions to define
doubt whether the candidate knows you
know what the IT best practices are or
not they'll want to see an ITIL
certification as just one of many
examples sixty percent of organizations
are now using these are these
certifications to confirm whether or not
you have the knowledge and expertise
that they need sixty-six percent of
employers consider IT certifications to
be very valuable sixty-six percent
that's up from the thirty percent in
2011 so in just five years the scales
have tipped from you know a good number
of organizations to a majority of
organizations considering those
certifications to be valuable and
necessary so if you haven't been looking
for work in the last five or ten years
things have changed out there and you
need to be aware of that so numbers like
that this helped make it really hard to
discount the validity of certifications
and we also know that all certifications
are not equal so you've got to research
the ones relevant to your job and then
which certification is best for example
we have prints too and PMP we have see
bap and the PMI equivalent to business
analysis we have several different
certifications for different IT service
modules as well research them and figure
out which one is required for your dream
jobs this information by the way if you
want to validate it for yourself can be
found at this sub CIO calm at this link
so what is itsm certification if you're
looking at the management type roles if
that's your dream job then you want to
consider an itsm type certification
there are two most common ones one is
the ITIL framework which is the most
widely accepted approach to IT Service
Management and you're probably going to
want either an intermediate or an expert
level you certainly will want the
foundation level a comparable
certification is the iso/iec 20001 and
it's an itsm certification that's
offered by the international standards
organization so you can go through any
registered certifying organization and
there's lots of information on on the
websites on how to get this so just two
examples of two different ones you can
get I would suggest you will want to get
if you're doing the IT Service
Management and you want to be the
management roles to do the ITIL because
it is the most widely accepted however
having multiple certifications does not
hurt your chances either so at this
point we've looked at how to become the
dream candidate how to get skills how to
demonstrate to employers that we are
ordering candidate for their particular
positions that they're they're hiring
for or that they need to create one for
us but then we have to find the
opportunities and figure out how to get
that job that is a huge job so what I
want to point out to you is something
that I certainly didn't appreciate until
about three years ago is the job
websites such as monster indeed linkedin
yahoo hotspots careerbuilder dice
craigslist and there there are many more
out there but these are some of the
bigger ones that you hear about I'm
going to share a personal story with you
I for a lark put my resume up on
LinkedIn that oh you know everybody's
talking about it i'll put my resume up
and i feel that a very sketchy pearls
I'll just so I'd have something
there and you know see what happened it
wasn't really looking for work because I
had lots of work but out of the blue I
got a call not from the organization I'm
with now but from another organization
wondering if I would do some training in
the city of ottawa because they had a
class and they didn't have the
instructor wasn't available that they
normally used and they saw that I had
some training experience on my resume
and wondered if I would do the course
and I was wow my part of my dream job
when I retire is that I'd like to be
able to do some training well I should
give this a shot absolutely so I signed
up and I did it found I loved it and now
I'm doing more and more of it all
because i had a pote I had my resume
posted on linkedin I didn't even look
I've trained for four or five different
companies now and as I've got more
experience I've gotten better positions
with with companies doing training so
that's just just one little experience
that I had and I haven't even I wasn't
even looking like I say so if you're
you're on their spend the time to do a
good profile that's where that homework
we talked about at the beginning about
knowing your skills knowing the titles
and what to call things will help you
get found so you want to know where to
look and where to get found there's both
aspects to that it's not just about you
searching and firing off a resume to
them anymore so let's take a look at
don't discount the smaller local
services if your dream job is working
for a smaller company and helping it
grow or you like that culture or that
environment better since a lot of the
jobs can be posted for free in cities
places like Craigslist you'll find jobs
posted there so don't discount those
don't think all the jobs are on the big
sites because these some of the bigger
sites you have to pay to list the job so
the smaller companies aren't going to
list their so I don't want to spend a
lot of time on these there's lots of
information out there but just to show
you a quick example the different sites
have different characteristics to them
most of them will let you select by
company you'll note jobs com is owned by
monster so some of them are actually the
same company so you have to watch for
that as well
if we look at indeed here they can
provide us with some good information on
trends so here I can look at in July
2015 the job trends were up for IT
technology jobs by nine percent media
ten percent real estate so we're looking
at IT jobs but again you can go and take
a look so diff don't just stop at one
site look at multiple sites linkedin
I've already mentioned it's a fairly big
one there are a lot of people that look
on there they have a professional level
where the people the recruiters sign up
so they can see more information so it's
a good one to be listed on careerbuilder
I haven't used but you'll notice it
shows you something really interesting
here it shows you employers are using
these keywords to search for candidates
remember I said you had to look for
those job titles and what the call
things well careerbuilder Khan is giving
you some of the top ones right off the
top on their landing page so again use
multiple sites check them out see what
works to help you find because each job
is going to be unique for each one of
you don't discount regional and national
and local resources i live in canada the
canadian government i just discovered
this doing the research for you because
whoops so I didn't because I did not
know this um has a job search site so if
you know you're only going to work in
your country this might be a good option
for you and there's probably ones for
within your city and things like that as
well so do check all your resources
spend some time looking for which job
sites are the best ones for you so now
we've assessed what we want we know what
we need to do to become the dream
candidate we know where to look for the
job and we know how to get found so now
we just need to land that job yeah
easier said than done isn't it first
create a master resume most of you
probably already have one I have a
24-page resume that lists every single
job I've ever done right back to high
school and all the skills required and
all the different roles responsibilities
not that I had that's
not the one I give to everyone though
most of them don't care about my high
school work experience or what I did 15
years ago however it does serve as a
quick and fast way to take that master
resume and then customize it
specifically for the dream job or any
job that you're applying for because I
consult I'm frequently having to update
my resume so I do find it useful to have
to have that and have all the skill sets
and that in it you may periodically have
to go back and rewrite your older job
descriptions not because you're changing
what you did but because the terminology
used today is different than it was back
then the work you did was the same so
for example I finds that some of the
work I did they now call it agile well a
lot of components of agile we were doing
in primate ten years ago we just didn't
call it agile we had a daily meeting to
look at what the problems were what we
were getting done today and how things
went yesterday we just didn't call it a
scrum meeting or a stand-up meeting so
make sure you keep it up-to-date create
a work portfolio and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
so again look at where to find jobs to
get found and make sure you post the
most recent information and maybe some
examples of your work there as well and
then we're going to take a look at the
interview itself so the master resume is
a document that lists and completely
describes all your work experience
accomplishments and training in one
place if you want some resume writing
tips a very good source that I have
found is that this link so you can link
there and get some more detailed
information than I can give you in this
session so one of the things that you
will learn if you if you do some
researching on on this is that
interviewers used to spot a great
applicant and invest time to learn about
the company and to craft a custom resume
so they'll use this so if you know a bit
about their company already they see
that as somebody who's keen who's
thorough whose professional
and I'll help you out they also know
that that's much easier to do now with
the internet so they're going to expect
a little more than maybe they did in the
past so customize your resume to them
and and make sure that you've
highlighted the information that's of
interest to them so if I'm applying for
a business architect an enterprise-wide
business architect role I don't bore
them with all my project management
experience they don't care they just
want to know whether I can do the
business architect work or not
conversely if I'm doing a project
management position that I'm applying
for they don't really care about the
business architecture work they're
interested than I know about it maybe
but they don't care that I had ten jobs
in it they only care about the project
management work that I did so make sure
you customize the resume to the job that
you're looking for create a work
portfolio I can't emphasize this enough
create a portfolio that has real
examples of your work so if you wrote a
business case you might have a sample of
that business case in there may be some
comparison charts that you did to do
some option analysis or help make
support decision-making highlight
business outcomes resulting from your
work remember at the beginning of the
presentation we talked about how
businesses are focused on if we're
looking for IT service rules their focus
on satisfying customers requirements and
meeting their business needs they don't
care that I implemented a network what
they care is did I implement a network
that helped them achieve their business
objectives so try to be extent possible
to couch the work that you've done in
terms of the outcomes achieved as a
result of that include your master
resume in the work portfolio so it's
kind of like your library of your work
include any letters of recommendation or
feedback from customers share any ideas
of the help out how you can help their
organization specifically any
organization in general such as
organizations you've looked for in the
past putting together a portfolio or a
binder I often will go in with a
briefcase
and sometimes a little more than that
just because of the range of work I've
done where I can pull out a binder and
show them this is what a process map
I've done looks like or pull out my
laptop and show here's how I've done a
process map for business architecture or
a conceptual diagram that shows and
links to the procedures and all those
kinds of things you might be bringing up
an infrastructure plan or a business
continuity plan that you've developed or
a change management process you
developed or procedure you developed
whatever your work is bring examples
because it communicates the quality of
the work your passion for the work and
your commitment it also shows that your
understanding where the interviewer is
coming from seeing is believing and
words are cheap especially in an
interview where you're you know people
are trying to put on their best for it
so if you can actually show something
much better landing the big one the best
way to land a big the great look long
before you need a job so you need to get
ready present yourself showing that you
have the right qualifications attitude
values work experience and contribution
vision how you can help the organization
a trees its strategic objectives how can
you do that if you can communicate that
that will set you apart from others now
let's get to the interview rehearse
answering tough questions and here are
some examples there's some more tips at
this website if you want to get some bud
there's additional questions there and
more tips on how to answer them but
think about them because you're going to
get asked some of these you're going to
get asked some difficult questions you
need to be able to they don't you don't
want them to sound rehearsed but they do
need to know that you understand and and
you need to be able to illustrate how
you would handle those tough questions
prepare mentally for the interview
visualize yourself succeeding get
exercise always be well as to exercise
but go for a walk or something clear
your mind make sure you're well
rested and minimize stressors look
successful go in looking the part it
will help you feel better so there's a
book that John Medina wrote called brain
rules and one of the things that he are
many of the things that he points out
but one of the one of the ones loss of
sleep hurts your attention executive
function and your working memory for
example so if you go in tired you're
going to be stumbling trying to recall
information to answer questions it also
impacts your logical reasoning when
you're not rested so that's not putting
you in a good position when you go into
that interview now there's a few other
rules if you want to go through the book
stress trains for example don't learn
the same way and they don't present or
they'll process information the same way
so if you want your best shot go and
rest it don't go in stressed if you can
help it and and look the parts you feel
better tedtalks has a special talk on
how to do some of those kinds of things
as well which is good don't stay up the
night before preparing okay because if
you do that then you're working against
the things we just went through in the
lungs on the last screen so don't stay
up till two or three o'clock in the
morning researching the company because
you've got an interview at eight o'clock
the next morning go to sleep be rested
and go in ready so that you're at your
best don't think negatively you can work
yourself into a very bad position where
you aren't going to present yourself
well don't envision yourself failing
don't skip reviewing job description
they posted a job they've requested you
to come for an interview make sure you
thoroughly understand what they're
looking for before you get there and
don't arrive late that does not set a
good example plus it leaves you stressed
and as we've already pointed out
stressed Minds don't work as effectively
so you're not going to perform as well
in the interview so in summary know what
your dream job is become the dream
candidate you guys are looking for each
other the dream employer in the dream
job is looking for the dream candidate
and vice versa
identify opportunities and put yourself
where you'll be found and then land the
job preparation is the key make sure
you're well prepared before you go in
and I just that's the end of my session
I do realize I guess I maybe need to
take a couple slides out that's a little
too close to our one-hour finish mark if
you need to contact us for additional
information I'll just leave this side up
chip I believe you want to come back in
when i was done so i'll just let you cut
me off as soon as you're ready to join
us again and that you can go ahead hi
absolutely this is great stuff I didn't
leave you much time I do apologize not a
problem not a problem oui oui hopefully
we have time to go over a few minutes I
don't think that we have another webinar
backed up behind us here so I'm sure
that our our our tech support will let
me know if we need to have a hard stop
at the half hour which is right now but
I want to let everybody know that I've
shared the all the various lengths that
had talked about into the chat screen so
i was able to validate all those links
and get them into the chat so go ahead
and look at that real quick if you want
to click through any of those any of the
tiny of those urls you can and go ahead
and research the resources that and that
was pointing about and we do have a
question here which is can you please
repeat the name of the book that you
mentioned right at the end you you
mentioned it would call brain rules by
john medina and the last name again
medina yep m.ed I n a and it's an
excellent book and it's a very quick
read brain rules last name is Medina
fantastic yeah thank you for that yeah
terrific terrific material I really
appreciate you being here to do that
it's it's you know having those hard
versus soft skills to that you mentioned
that positive attitude and the culture
phit being so critical alongside the
skills training in the sir
vacation so you know having all of those
all of those aspects that you can bring
to the job and bring to bear so so
valuable a couple of quick questions
before we have to bug out here let me
take a look real quick and try to choose
the one that'll be the the most valuable
for everybody that's still listening you
mentioned getting a career coach at one
point to help kind of help you define
and figure out the the dream situation
for yourself are there any other besides
a career coach any other services or
tools that you'd recommend to get
clarity on your own strengths and
talents things you know I'm thinking
like a Tony Robbins style workshop or a
personality test like a Briggs Myers are
those sorts of things also helpful to
gain per se are they are and actually a
career coach will take you through those
they did do when i went to the seat
across they did do the myers-briggs test
with me and and a few other things along
those lines so they can really point you
to but yes a Tony Robbins style to a
session could be good or doing an online
version of a myers-briggs personality
assessment or jobs and skills set fit
would be would be also good sources good
ideas chip good good to know I imagine
you I love the idea that you have their
writing up that master resume that goes
all the way back through every job that
you've ever had even if you're not going
to show the entire thing to people I
imagine doing that all by itself is a
great exercise to sort of shine a light
on the kinds of trends of experience
that you've had and as you're doing it
you're probably going to go oh yeah I
really liked that job I know that job
really sucked and it might just be a
great exercise to help you sort of hone
it so that you really enjoy and also how
to bring some of the skills that you
learn from one job into a new situation
to you are absolutely right it
absolutely does because it'll it will
sort of you we know that we r memory
gets stimulated when we start redoing
things we've done before so by doing
that it will highlight you know maybe a
certain person that we worked with what
we liked about that person you know for
example I worked with a fellow that he
could tell you you did something wrong
and you didn't even realize it until
three days later because he would ask
you questions you
oh I guess I should have known the
answer to that before he had to ask me
the question shouldn't I but he just has
such a smooth way about him as a
director uses somebody I really liked
working for and I've sought out someone
like him as a you know a mentor or a
boss every sense so you're absolutely
right that's that's an exercise i think
that i'm going to undertake myself here
very quickly just just not because i'm
looking for a job but just to have that
personal insight into what i really the
things that i enjoy doing and the things
that maybe i don't enjoy doing that
would be exciting to go back over what
now is something like 40 years of
experience like yourself i'm a gray hair
too by the way sound like you're about
20 oh well that's if only I look the way
I sound but yeah that's I think I'm
looking at the other questions that came
through and I think that they came up
and then as you move through your
materials we pretty much covered it yeah
people were asking about are there
specific blogs or publications that
you'd recommend our conferences and any
and you mentioned looking for those
things I don't know if you have any
particular publications or conferences
that you reckon to keep on top of IT
service trends I don't and partly
because it really depends on the
specific rule that you're looking for
it'll it'll vary so widely depending on
whether you're a practitioner and
hardware or you're managing a you know a
security service or whether you're
managing a web hosting type service it
really does various you really need to
look them up for for the particular role
you're looking for and all of that
depends on doing this homework to figure
out that all right yeah unfortunately if
you were looking for a silver bullet out
of this session I don't quite have that
it's just short cuts to the work that
actually has to be done but hopefully
it'll save some time and some research
and give you some confidence in what you
need to do to go about finding that job
alright well until next time hopefully
you and I'll get a chance to work
together again and to everybody else
thank you so much for joining us have a
terrific rest of your morning afternoon
or evening if you're somewhere in the
middle of Asia on the other side of the
globe and you stayed up to the middle of
the night to join us we sure appreciate
that and
with all that said thank you so much and
we will see you the next time take care
everybody bye bye
you